увага до трагедії волинівці досягла
такого масштабу що власне розслідування
має намір проводити організацію
Об'єднаних Націй за словами генсека
антоніо-готеріша ООН не може проводити
кримінальне розслідування але може
запустити власну місію для встановлення
фактів
Ми шукаємо компетентних незалежних людей
яких можна було б включити до цієї місії
щодо встановлення фактів Ми сподіваємося
що обидві сторони дадуть можливості для
доступу та отримання всіх даних
необхідних для з'ясування правди про те
що сталося до цього питання ми
поставилися дуже серйозно І ми
наполегливо працюємо над цим
повідомляється що внаслідок удару по
сезону оленівці на території
самопроголошеної ДНР загинуло понад 50
військових ЗСУ взятих у полон у середині
травня на заводі Азовсталь у Маріуполі
понад 70 отримали поранення Росія та
Україна з одна одну Москва заявляє про
обстріл СІЗО із установок himers Київ
заперечується і стверджує що будівлю
підірвали бійці приватної військової
компанії Вагнер без погодження з
мінобороне РФ щоб приховати допити і
застосуванням тортур а також факти
тотального розкрадання коштів виділених
на утримання українських
військовополонених відомо що 1 серпня на
об'єкт мала прибути комісія з Москви для
перевірки видатків виділених коштів та
умов утримання полонених заявили в Києві
у Росії запевняють що нібито офіційно
запросили на місце експертів ООН та
міжнародного комітету Червоного Хреста
однак там навпаки стверджують що досі не
отримали відповіді на свій запит нам
досі не надали доступу до поранених
військовополонених і Ми не отримали
гарантії безпеки щоб провести огляд
місця вибуху ми запропонували допомогти
в евакуації поранених пожертвувати
препарати захисник екіпірування та
матеріали написала лабораторної
експертизи наша пропозиція залишилися
без відповіді Червоний Хрест Має
отримати негайний доступ до СІЗО в
оленівці та інших місць куди привезли
поранених та тіла загиблих компанія
максар опублікувала супутникові знімки
місця трагедії фото свідчить про те що
будівля розірвалася зсередини вважає
український військовий експерт Олег
Жданов за його словами волинівці міг
бути застосований термобаритний заряд
боєприпас Що випалює кисень
у мене дуже великі сумніви щодо обстрілу
як офіцер артилерист скажу що під час
вибухів чорного диму не може бути а під
час пострілів так ця хмара мала б
виглядати як під час фугасного вибуху а
тут більше схоже що ці вибухи були
внутрішніми у будівлі аніж зовнішніми що
проникають через покрівлю будівель
Ну і що найголовніше фотографії та відео
зсередини Справа в тому що всі ліжка
стоять на своїх місцях і тіла лежать там
де стоять ліжка під час фугасного вибуху
ліжка і тіла мало б розмітати по всіх
кутках цієї будівлі мало б вибити вікна
зірвати дах і якщо цих вибухів було
декілька То були б руйнування самої
будівлі тріщини в стінах і вся стіна з
внутрішньої сторони яка закопчена на
відео повинна була б бути посічена тими
сотнями тисяч осколків які утворюються
внаслідок погасного вибуху але
штукатурка на стіні абсолютно ціла
фугасного взрыва но штукатурка на стене
абсолютно цеглая з моменту трагедії вже
минув майже тиждень міжнародні експерти
потраплять на місце із великим
запізненням це можна до цього моменту
приховати всі Докази і чи справді
вдасться провести розслідування єслі
якщо фахівці досвідчені якщо допустять
туди криміналістів то думаю що вони
можуть взяти нагар і визначити тип
вибухової речовини це відповість на
запитання який тип вибухової речовини
застосовувався за характером вибуху буде
визначено який тип вибухом які
боєприпаси застосовувалися бо начинка
боєприпасів різна виробництво втратило
теж різне Це було б добре
[музика]
это было бы хорошо джерело агентства
асушіє тут пресс знайомий з висновками
розвіт служб стверджує Москва
намагається створити враження що
відповідальність за трагедію несе Київ
тим часом у Києві родичі полонених
захисників азовсталі влаштували акцію на
софійській площі під назвою Оленівка
новий Освенцим учасники вимагали від
Червоного Хреста зробити все можливе щоб
отримати доступ до військовополонених та
гарантувати їхню безпеку забезпечити
мінімальну фізіологічні необхідні
умови існування Там людей до тих пір
поки не відбудеться військовий обмін
якісь людські умови якесь харчування
необхідна медична допомога Ну і гарантія
того що ви їх просто не вб'ють
Наступного разу
на акцію прийшли понад 300 людей серед
них родичі військовополонених бійців
Азову однією з причин трагедії в
оленівці вони називають бездіяльність
міжнародних організацій
вони повинні були знаходитись там але за
два з половиною місяці їх там ні разу не
було хоча б дивитися щоб над ним не
знущались і щоб вони були в нормальних
умовах
учасники акції влаштували перформанс на
якому показали як 29 липня ймовірно були
вбиті десятки українських полонених
волинівці
Ольга Наречена одного з воїнів Азову
який перебував у полоні в оленівці
дівчина досі не отримала жодної
інформації про те чи живий її коханий
ми Закликаємо говорити про цю трагедію
весь світ тому що
якщо зараз таке вже коїться з хлопцями у
полоні ми не знаємо чого очікувати далі
много Христа ми досі не отримали ніякої
інформації Хоча вони мали бути гарантами
безпеки наших хлопців У полоні А зараз
вони відхрещуються від своєї роботи яку
вони мають виконувати
у свою чергу Міжнародний комітет
Червоного Хреста заявив що він виступав
в ролі нейтрального посередника для
безпечного виходу військових з Азов
сталі і не міг гарантувати безпеку
військовополонених які опинилися в руках
противника а Забезпечення захисту
військовополонених від будь-яких актів
насильства заляковині тортур є
обов'язком сторони яка сама ж і утримує
цих людей вважають у червоному хресті